chile is facing its moment of truth
more than two years ago the country
began a complex process of rewriting its
constitution and now it's up to the
people to decide what happens next
[Music]
and his wife rosa sanchez have been
selling candies at kiosk just outside
the conventions building for the past
decades
[Music]
foreign
ahead of the referendum that will take
place in september surveys show tillians
are divided on whether the draft fixes
what's wrong
it all began in late 2019 when anger
over a surprise increase in the subway
fair unleashed a massive wave of
protests over poor social services
inequality and other systemic issues
to defuse tensions then president
sebastian pinera agreed to a process to
replace the constitution put in place by
dictator augusto pinochet
the idea got brought support
critics of the current constitution
argue that somehow elements of the text
contribute to inequality and weak social
security net while giving the private
sector to dominant overall in providing
public services but on the other hand
many are afraid that in this process
chile could lose some of its
pro-business rule that they argue have
made to lay an example of the developing
world for economic growth in the past
decades
chile is held up as a country that broke
free of the bonds of dictatorship in
1990
it built a stable democracy and a sound
economy
the nation became the poster child for
the power of free markets boosting
growth and lifting people out of poverty
today chile is among the richest nations
in latin america
ricardo montero represented chile's
socialist party as a delegate at the
convention he sees the new constitution
as the starting point in solving a
fundamental problem
but
even after years of growth chile suffers
from one of the biggest gaps between
rich and poor among developed
countries some people feared chile could
lose the policies that have enabled the
country's growth marcella cuvillos
represented the right-wing coalition at
the convention
a
[Music]
the final draft gives the government a
bigger role in offering public services
it also boosts the representation of
women and the indigenous community it
gives regions outside the capital more
decision-making powers
it toughens environmental restrictions
on chile's all-important mining and
lithium industries
[Music]
a democracy
[Music]
does not think the state can do this
without the business community support
chile is undergoing a very unique
process of self-discovery that will
serve either as a warning or as a
template for other countries that are
trying to tackle climate change and
inequality if jillian's approved the
delegate's proposal in september it will
be months if not years before congress
can turn it into law
if people reject the draft chile goes
back to the drawing board